last autumn 200 workers lost their jobs
here in Bhutan northern France when
their steel plant closed its owner the
Russian steel maker NL MK had wanted to
sell it but couldn't find a buyer for
more than a century the plant had been a
pillar of the local economy the workers
say they can't understand why the
government did nothing to prevent the
closure the authorities should protect
our industries especially in small towns
and rural regions we were a really good
team in Belgium the regional government
bought 49% of an LMK plant why does the
Belgian state do it and the French state
doesn't pourquoi database luffy it it of
course in your paper many of the former
steel workers are disappointed not only
by the government but also by the
mainstream political parties the first
round of the French presidential
election is to be held on the 23rd of
April neither the left nor the right
have done anything for us I'm going to
vote for the National Front at least
they'll send all the foreign workers
home then we'll get their jobs lots of
foreigners have been taking our jobs we
French people should have priority
the only way they are done would be many
companies in this part of northern
France have closed down over the past
few decades the unemployment rate in
some towns is 16% or higher
people here feel abandoned left high and
dry many find the arguments or the
slogans of a far-right National Front
appealing five mayors in the region
represent the party one of them is
horribly for envy a katli we want
tariffs to put an end to unfair
competition from abroad
and the euro is bad for us we can't
boost exports by having a weaker
currency only by depressing wages he
sounds rather like Donald Trump the new
US president also wants to impose
tariffs on imports to the United States
I think he's got the right idea of
course the Americans want to act in
their own interests but they're asking
the right questions and others will
follow suit what we're witnessing is the
end of a certain economic model that's
been sold to us in such a dogmatic
manner before denies that protectionist
measures could harm French firms for
example if they have to pay more for
imports he believes the risks of an open
economy and of an open society are
greater it's dangerous to admit three
hundred thousand foreigners every year
they don't want to integrate
we have to put an end to this political
wishful thinking that says we can all
just hold hands and get along that's not
the way the world works people here want
to see Trump style protectionism
enforced in France to Mayor belief or
says many want to see change including
the local estate agents for example many
of our clients are having a hard time
keeping their businesses running in the
face of tough competition from Eastern
Europe where pay is much lower
that hits small companies especially
hard to talk to you she's all for them
mr. Trump is on the right track when he
says he wants to see jobs at the local
and national level we saw how he dealt
with the car makers the aim is to bring
jobs back home
the sawmill at the edge of town is run
by Alec sharp aunty he says French
companies need some degree of protection
including his own it's now competing
with companies as far away as China
which buy up lots of timber from France
he says the situation is not sustainable
we need a steady supply of raw materials
otherwise our factory will grind to a
halt the government should ensure that
French timber remains in France so that
our lumber and woodworking industry can
survive pontius says the European Union
needs to do its part as well to protect
European industries the EU should take
tougher measures to protect the economy
with respect to imports and exports they
could learn a lesson or two from China
and now from the US as well it's too
late to revive the steel plant in botar
other jobs in the area are hard to find
of the 200 who have lost their
livelihoods only 30 have so far found a
new job we meet and try to cheer each
other up especially when somebody is
feeling really desperate and is having a
particularly lousy day we're there for
each other even though NL Mk isn't there
for us anymore in America they're not
giving up without a fight they're filing
suit demanding a better severance
package some spent their entire working
life at the plant and sadly it's time to
wrap things up for now but join us next
week when we'll once again focus on
protectionism this time in Europe and
particularly in Britain Prime Minister
Theresa May has made it clear that her
government wants a clean break with
Europe the people who work in the
creative industries in London are
totally against
hard brexit they're mobilizing in favor
of open borders and raising their voices
against protectionism and all it stands
for many businesses in Britain on the
other hand seem to be adopting a
pragmatic approach to the new
circumstances some think the nation's
export sector will profit from a weaker
pound and are hoping to strike a quick
trade deal with the new US president